l'étoile de la miss france préférait de
cyril delphine wespiser qu'est ce que ça
change et depuis peu ok a dit ça mais je
les allées entendu je les ai vus à
tahiti ouais ça n'a rien ne vous mettez
une part là-bas tu me le disent les yeux
dans les yeux marchons tous linta
réfléchi deux jours qu'est ce qu'il en
est je vais te dire mais je vous le dis
on joue bien savoir pourquoi pas mettre
tout le temps d'appel dans cette
émission non plus je vais te dire alors
je vais te dire alors je vais te dire la
vérité moi tout ça j'aime beaucoup les
jeunes fij m en coulant autour du bureau
c'est vous allez mentir j'aime beaucoup
la gente féminine
parce que je la respecte mais je vais
vous dire vous vous êtes bien sûr très
jolie elle est très jolie mais aucune
des données monde et l'irlande et l'ira
voilà je préfère le dire comme ça c'est
clair c'est de la réponse comme moi on
aime parce qu'on n'est pas satisfait de
là elles vous donneront déjà la réponse
[Rires]
j'ai même twitté
comme quoi vous étiez toujours à miss
préférée mais je savais qu'un mauvais
compte en fait il a traîné avec un
mauvais moyen mauvais comptes chez elle
pour que ça arrive pas nos oreilles moi
j'ai un pote qui me dit un régatier a
twitté sur twilight ou sur toi et du
couvre feu que je voulais la la réponse
chez moi
on est venu pour faire une émission est
de regrouper choi le postulat de départ
si on vient on est en train de chine et
maintes fois la mêlée
faudel film tu sais que je t'adore tu es
toujours ma préférée rejet n'est pas
venu aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui du
coup et la faune ouais je sais c'est
rétro l'important mettre les choses au
clair que la vérité soit faite et je
sais pas combien de retirer l'antenne de
sa télé a rougi